quand est ce que je serai remboursé
puis je faire une cure thermale cette
année je pars en vacances à l'étranger
est ce que ma mutuelle voyage avec moi
vous avez toujours plein de question
pour nous et c'est tant mieux car nous
sommes là pour y répondre
téléphonez nous ou demander à être
rappelé tout est clair et précis sur
notre site
une mutuelle qui vit avec vous votre
quotidien
c'est ça une mutuelle qui va bien
revenez clic et on en parle
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans
check-up votre émission santé et
bien-être
au programme dans ce numéro nous nous
sommes rendus à une conférence organisée
par l'hôpital charcot de plaisir
conférence autour du thème de la
prévention du suicide en institution
nous vous présenterons également
l'externat médico-éducatif d'elancourt
et le projet des étudiants de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
visant à collecter des fonds pour
améliorer le centre et pour terminer
direction l'hôpital des nounours à
versailles un hôpital qui n'ouvre qu'une
fois par an où l'on y rencontre des
patients très spéciaux mais pour
commencer nous allons parler de
l'association anaïs du rêve à l'espoir
anaïs une petit plaisir oise de cinq ans
est atteinte d'infirmité moteur cérébral
et de tetra paresi cette maladie rare ne
bénéficient pas de traitement suffisant
en france obligeant les parents à
financer des soins à l'étranger
les traitements très haut niveau et non
reconnu par la france et donc non
remboursés isabelle olivier la merde
anaïs a donc créé cette association pour
aider au financement des soins à
l'étranger
ils ont d'ailleurs participé à la course
du printemps organisé par la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux camille lambert
était sur place
nous avons créé l'association il y a
trois ans parce que notre fille est
atteinte d'infirmité motrice cérébrale
due à un accident à la naissance
manque d'oxygène et en fait on a récolté
on a créé cette association pour
récolter des fonds pour nous permettre
de financer des thérapies de rééducation
que l'on fait pour la plupart à
l'étranger est également pour nous aider
à financer le matériel médical qui
extrêmement cher pour les enfants
handicapés
cet argent fait nous sert
essentiellement donc à financer ces
thérapies mais également à
à payer par exemple à fauteuil roulant
électrique que l'on devoir va devoir
acquérir prochainement
prévenir le suicide accompagné les
familles mais aussi le personnel
depuis deux ans le centre hospitalier
jean-martin-charcot organise des
journées de conférences et de tables
rondes auprès du personnel de santé
celle de cette année était axée sur le
thème du suicide en institution comme
dans les hôpitaux psychiatriques
un reportage de mélanie poquet soutenir
les personnes touchées par un suicide en
institution éviter les effets
d'imitation c'est ce qu'on appelle la
postvention le thème choisi par le
centre hospitalier jean marie charcot
lors de sa conférence annuelle
alors la postvention et l ensemble des
démarches et ou de dispositifs qu'on met
en place à la suite d'une tentative de
suicide ou de suicides avérés
donc tout ce qui concerne pas les
soutiens quand peut amener aux personnes
qui sont concernées affecté par cet
événement en 2011 plus de 11000 suicides
ont été enregistrés en france et les
milieu médicalisé sont aussi concernés
même si les données ne sont pas connues
c'est difficile les institutions sont là
pour protéger pour aider et quand ça
arrive mais on a confronté vraiment des
situations très difficiles
donc effectivement ça reste encore un
peu tabou
on espère que justement part par le fait
d'en parler par le fait de pouvoir se
soutenir les uns les autres ça devienne
moins et donc ça nous rend demain un
corps meilleur pour accompagner les
personnes qui en ont besoin
c'est un axe de prévention du suicide
extrêmement fort qui permet de préserver
les personnels des institutions dans
leur capacité de travail et dans leur
capacité à pouvoir continuer sur le plan
personnel et donc c'est un axe de
prévention qui permet à la fois
d'accompagner le personnel est
d'accompagner les résidents ou des
patients dans les institutions
organisé en partenariat avec le
groupement d'études et prévention du
suicide
ces journées annuelles vise à former les
personnels des institutions pour mieux
accompagner les familles aient levé un
tabou
les étudiants se mobilisent en faveur de
l'externat médico-éducatif d'elancourt
la structure qui accueille des jeunes
atteints de déficience intellectuelle a
reçu le soutien de cinq étudiants de
l'université de versailles saint quentin
un projet baptisé en diact qui a pour
but d'aider à l'organisation de la
première journée portes ouvertes de
l'établissement mais aussi la
construction d'un jardin adapté
l'objectif récolter des fonds via une
plateforme de financement participatif
répondre aux besoins des enfants grâce à
un accompagnement social et médical tous
les jours à l'externat médico éducatif
de la clé saint-pierre à elancourt des
jeunes polyhandicapés viennent ici pour
travailler sur des activités
quotidiennes
nous accompagnons 25 jeunes
polyhandicapés de ce héros à 20 ans ces
jeunes viennent tous les jours en
externat donc du matin jusqu'en fin
d'après midi
et c'est une équipe interdisciplinaire
donc qui propose un projet personnalisé
d'accompagnement à chacun une structure
que des étudiants de l'université de
versailles saint quentin ont décidé
d'aider dans le cadre de leur master ces
cinq jeunes ont créé un projet social en
faveur du centre
l'objectif récolter des fonds en vue de
la future journée portes ouvertes mais
aussi la création d'un jardin adapté
on est environ 13 1500 euros pour le
financement complet du jardin zen donc
la première action qu'on a mis en place
c'est la plateforme kiss kiss bang bang
de récolte de fonds qui se termine dans
dix jours
aujourd'hui cette cagnotte elle est à
presque 4000 euros on est à 3500 3600 et
quelques euros est l'objectif
au travers de cette plateforme est
énormément de récolter 500 euros pour
l'organisation de la journée portes
ouvertes et tout le surplus serait
reversée à l'oeil mais en fait pour
contribuer à ce financement
une opération qui commence bien et aussi
le début d'une belle histoire puisque
les jeunes ne comptent pas s'arrêter là
au-delà de cette plateforme on souhaite
mettre en place par exemple le montage
de dossiers de demande de financement
on veut aussi peut-être aller vers les
entreprises qui proposent ces devis et
négocier les prix une récolte qui
permettrait aux enfants du centre de
bénéficier d'une cour de récréation
adaptées à leurs besoins et qui semble
susciter l'engouement général
puisqu'elle a déjà rassemblé plus d'une
centaine de donateurs
c'est une opération qui existe depuis
maintenant 10 ans mise en place par la
nef et l'association poèmes qui regroupe
les étudiants en médecine de
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
l'hôpital des nounours a ouvert ses
portes pendant deux jours le 15 et 18
mars à versailles et à vélizy destinée
aux enfants de grande section de
maternelle
elle a pour objectif de faire découvrir
la santé de manière ludique et
pédagogique grâce aux étudiants en
médecine pour reportage c'est un hôpital
un peu spécial un hôpital qui ouvre une
fois par an où les patients sont des
peluches sabrina accompagne son nounours
petit ours brun qui a la grippe
première étape consultation avec un
docteur pour le diagnostic chez dans la
salle des consultations et donc on
s'occupe d'accueillir les enfants avec
leurs nounous oms et de leur demander
le problème qu'ils ont le prénom de leur
d'une hausse leur prénom à eux aussi et
on met un peu en marche le début des
soins prise de température prescription
de médicaments petit ours brun aura même
droit à un carnet de santé une carte
vitale avant de passer en salle de soins
maintenant le ciel dr qu'est-ce qu'on a
alors vu qu'il a la grive terme est un
piège il a un peu fou ce qu'on va faire
on va le mettre une compresse froide
sabrina pourra même participer aux soins
de son nounours comme un premier contact
avec le monde des blouses blanches
aujourd'hui parce qu'elle a la grippe
ainsi que hélène tisné craquer victoire
et bayeux opérer ici tout est prévu bloc
opératoire dentiste ou radiographie
aujourd'hui ce sont 110 enfants de
grande section de maternelle qui auront
amené leur nounours pour une première
sensibilisation qui profite à tout le
monde c'est surtout un peu une première
sensibilisation parce qu'en 4ème année
on a un stage obligatoire de pédiatrie
donc on se retrouve confronté aux
enfants auxquels on n'a pas forcément
l'habitude de se comporter avec eux et
du coup le pic est lé nounours c'est un
peu une première approche pour nous pour
s'habituer on en rappelle des la
consultation on les prévient que ça se
soigne très bien et à la fin du parcours
on leur rappelle que le nom s'est soigné
dans la salle d'attenté on revient à les
voir pour vérifier que le nounours ouais
bien soigné leur rappeler et on retourne
même dans les classes deux semaines plus
tard pour leur rappeler leurs noms se
soigner aujourd'hui c'est une trentaine
d'étudiants en médecine de seconde année
qui ont opéré toute la journée dans un
hôpital où chaque patient vos sorts
guéri
et pour terminer vous l'attendiez tous
certainement alors tous à vos crayons
voici l'agenda pour commencer
rendez-vous tous les vendredis à 14
heures au centre social municipal
d'elancourt pour des séances de remise
en forme avec un programme complet
cardio relaxation ou massage tout est
prévu pour retrouver le tonus dans une
ambiance décontractée et puis le 31 mars
direction trappe pour une rencontre
santé autour de la nutrition un
événement partenariat avec la mutualité
française
vous aurez l'occasion de rencontrer des
professionnels pour faire le point sur
vos habitudes alimentaires et trouver
des solutions adaptées à votre mode de
vie
ça se passe au centre de santé municipal
de 10h à 12h et de 14h à 17h voilà check
up c'est maintenant terminé quant à moi
je vous donne rendez-vous dans deux
semaines pour un prochain numéro
et d'ici là surtout prenez soin de vous